Yippee ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm talking Rampage deleted scenes
and rejected concepts plus an alternate ending
and a post-credits scene we never got to see.
If you're new to my channel and enjoy this,
be sure to subscribe and ring the bell to
get all my new movie breakdowns and deleted
scenes videos.
Obviously, spoilers ahead for the movie, so
take care if you haven't it yet.
Let's kick things off with the original ending
to Rampage which was going to finish on a
rather sad note with the albino silverback
George sacrificing himself to save the day.
When the movie's star Dwayne Johnson read
the original script, his reaction was "Did
I miss something?
George can't be dead."
Speaking to Rolling Stone, Johnson explained
that he doesn't like sad endings because "Life
brings that [and] I don't want it in my movies.
When the credits roll, I want to feel great.
To try and win Johnson over, the movie's producers
took him through all the reasons they thought
the gorilla should die, saying that he would
be sacrificing himself "like a brave soldier"
to save the world and kill the animals who
would harm humans.
However, Johnson wasn't impressed and reminded
the producers that they weren't "making Saving
Private Ryan", but a movie with "a crocodile
the size of a football stadium".
Still, it took about two months for the film's
production to resolve the issue and they eventually
settled on a compromise which you can see
in the final movie when George plays a prank
on Johnson's character Davis by pretending
to be dead.
I think the fact that Johnson managed to change
the ending to the film speaks to the power
that the wrestler-turned-actor has in Hollywood.
In fact, it made me think of Frank Sinatra
who started out as a singer, but whose increasing
influence in 1950s Hollywood allowed him to
change the ending of his film Young At Heart.
As for Johnson, it's clear that he knows his
public very well.
Indeed, he's said that, "I have a relationship
with an audience around the world […] For
years I've built a trust with them that they're
gonna come to my movies and feel good.
So every once in a while, you have to drop
this card, which is [...] we need to figure
something out, otherwise I'm not gonna do
the movie."
In the end, Rampage's director Brad Peyton
agreed that Johnson's ending was better and
said that The Rock "understands the audience
and his relationship with the audience better
than anyone."
So, at the end of Rampage, George is still
alive, but he's too big to go back to San
Diego Zoo and as the Rock and George head
off, you might be thinking that this is gearing
up a sequel.
And you'd be right.
In fact, Brad Peyton actually filmed a post-credits
sequence that was going to set up a potential
Rampage 2.
It was a scene that the director really liked
and it also included a cameo from his girlfriend's
parents, however, in the end, the filmmakers
chose not to include it as they didn't want
to tie down the storyline of a future sequel
at this stage.
Peyton has said he's hoping the scene will
be included on the Blu-ray and DVD release
though.
Something that fans of the original Rampage
games might have missed seeing in the movie
was mutated humans.
In the games, it's typically human characters
who mutate into the monsters via experiments.
Including mutated humans in the story was
initially considered for the movie though
it only got as far as the pitch phase, the
reason being that director Brad Peyton says
he found it "hard to relate to" and just couldn't
see how it would work in the final film.
Ultimately, he felt that concept would have
turned the film into something like a "werewolf
movie" which is not what he wanted.
Speaking to Bloody Disgusting, Peyton said
"Tone is a big thing for me.
I want these movies to be fun.
People use the word absurd, but I also think
it's important to ground them slightly so
that some of the emotion can be real."
It seems that for Peyton, then, mutated humans
was one step too far for the crazy movie universe
of Rampage.
Another change from the video game was making
George an albino gorilla rather than brown
as he is in most of the games.
The reason for this change was principally
to make sure that George and Rampage felt
different to other movies in the genre such
as King Kong and Planet of the Apes.
Although, initially, there were concerns that
it might be hard to get the look of an albino
gorilla right and make him appear badass enough,
in the end, the filmmakers felt that the design
choice was a striking and effective one.
Now, in the last scene, after Davis tells
George that he and Naomie Harris's character
Dr Kate Caldwell are friends, let's just say
that George asks if that friendship comes
with any benefits, at which point Davis tells
George that he should have some class.
However, while there's no real romantic scene
between Harris and Johnson's characters in
the final movie, one was actually filmed!
Yes, Naomie Harris has confirmed that a kissing
scene between her and Johnson was cut from
the movie.
In fact, when InStyle asked Harris what it
was like shooting that, she went so far as
to say that, compared to her other on-screen
kisses, The Rock has the best lips in Hollywood!
So, did you enjoy Rampage and what do you
think about the alternate ending and deleted
scenes?
And would you like to see a Rampage sequel?
Let me know in the comments below plus you
can tweet me @Jan_Gilbert or @FlicksCity.
And if you enjoyed this, a thumbs-up is really
appreciated and you can tap here to check
out more great movie deleted scenes and movie
breakdowns.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!